ben c'est un bon jour vous vous trouvez
à tunis un confinement moins strictes
mises en place un vaccin qui peine à
arriver quelles sont les nouvelles
mesures prises par le gouvernement
effectivement des nouvelles mesures ont
été annoncées hier par le ministère de
la santé après quatre jours de
confinement total sur l'ensemble du pays
objectif de lutter contre cette
propagation du coronavirus qui semble ne
plus être maîtrisé par le gouvernement
il faut savoir que les hôpitaux sont
saturés 100 % des lits en réanimation
sont occupés malgré les quelques
hôpitaux de fortune qui ont été mis en
place partout dans le pays
c'est insuffisant encore comprendre en
charge tout elle est malade la plupart
d'entre eux restent à la maison et c'est
d'avoir des soins comme ils peuvent mais
c'est un petit peu compliqué pour le
moment mais pour les tests pcr
impossible d'en faire en masse car le
test coûte cher en lui-même il n'est pas
remboursé par le gouvernement quatre
jours donc confinement qui se sont
terminées hier soir à partir
d'aujourd'hui c'est un nouveau
confinement moins stricte certes car les
personnes ne peuvent se déplacer les
veuves se rendre au travail les magasins
ont rouvert ainsi que les mosquées les
restaurants et bars les cafés mais avec
de nouvelles mesures tout ce qui est bar
restaurant café ils peuvent servir mais
simplement à en porter un coup dur pour
l'ensemble de la profession qui vit
actuellement une crise économique sans
précédent et ça c'est nouveau pour tous
les tunisiens sur l'ensemble du pays aux
objectifs du gouvernement vraiment
essayé de limiter cette propagation en
attendant qu'un virus puissent être
fournis il ya déjà un accord qui a été
passé avec le groupe pfizer avec une
raison qui est prévu normalement pour le
mois de mars
et puis des négociations ont eu lieu la
semaine dernière avec l'ambassadeur de
russie en tunisie pour l'acquisition du
vaccin spoutnik v mais c'est encore en
discussion malgré le fait aussi que
l'algérie le pays voisin a promis à la
tunisie de lui livrer la moitié des
vaccins qui s'est procuré les vaccins
russe qui s'est procuré mais ça reste
encore à confirmer
voilà ce qu'on peut dire sur cette
situation pour le moment en tunisie avec
des sports des déplacements pardon qui
sont est limitée une interdiction de
rassemblement bien sûr encore pour les
jours à venir
et puis ce confinement et s'est
accompagnée à
par de vives tensions partout dans le
pays bassam des tensions ont éclaté il
ya à peu près 3 4 jours ça a coïncidé
avec le premier jour du confinement un
jour qui a été choisi par le
gouvernement n'ont pas au hasard car
c'était le jour de la célébration des 10
ans de la révolution tunisienne de 2011
étudiants s'étaient préparés à pouvoir
célébrer ce jour avec des manifestations
des rassemblements sur l'ensemble du
pays des sittings des concerts et puis
senna passerait pas eu lieu à cause de
ce confinement généralisée total sur
l'ensemble du pays
une annonce qui a été mal prise par
l'ensemble du pays l'ensemble des
cliniciens la raison pour laquelle des
tensions ont commencé à éclater à partir
de la nuit notamment dans les quartiers
populaires de la banlieue ouest de tunis
et puis dans d'autres villes s'est
généralisé progressivement le
gouvernement a peur que de nouvelles
tensions éclatent ce soir alors que le
confinement est terminée et tunisie est
bien sûr remettez en question de ce jour
de confinement qui coïncide avec la
célébration du dixième anniversaire de
la révolution mais également pour dire
au gouvernement qu'il n'en pouvait plus
car les prix au nom de nos montées et
devient difficile pour les unir de
pouvoir vivre de pouvoir s'alimenter et
même certains des salaires ne sont pas
payés en temps et en heure avec des
retards kipawa temps des fois deux trois
voire quatre mois on a pu assister à pas
mal de tension dans le quartier
populaire entre la police et des jeunes
avec l'été magasins qui ont été saccagés
et pillés du mobilier urbain aussi
saccagé et puis de vives tensions qu'on
a vu vraiment voir c'était inédit pour
les tunisiens qui n'avait pas vécu ça
depuis dix ans la révolution merci pour
toutes ces précisions direct depuis
tunis